and we're live hello good morning good
afternoon wherever you are in the world
and welcome to cyre your Sci-Fi TV and
Movie Channel with um special guest with
us H it's it's Matt no it's not it's
Jen hey we've been trying to get you on
for ages Jen so finally finally we got
you
on but hello everybody how are we all it
is amazing good morning well good
morning for me um I it is a Saturday
morning I am a little slow on the uptake
so I've definitely got my gigantic cup
of coffee things are great it's gorgeous
it's fall how about you guys oh it's
raining here it's early evening for me
so oh I'm right with you Jenny I woke up
maybe an hour ago I traded coffee for a
coconut
water it's I mean I'm just pretending
this is
vodka you it's so early it's so early
but
in the morning so we got Jen on so there
ex I'd love to tell us a little bit
about your career and why and why you
with this but really we're here because
it is the 29th anniversary today of the
Stargate movie being released in the
United States didn't come out over here
until like mid January
but right in America so um we thought
we'd get you one we talk about a
Stargate we got a couple of other things
to talk about as well one big rumor
about another TV show I apologize for
everyone in that that the sound isn't
great today but it's um it's it's
Jenny's fault and I okay it is totally
my fault it's tot my
Reaper um but Jen first yeah tell us a
little bit about like sort of your
career and and and and the sort the
shows you've worked on because to be
honest it's a list of just
amazingness um so what I do now is I am
a consultant and I do fandom development
so it's audience development for TV
series or films or or books that are
sci-fi fantasy geek related so what that
means is that I make sure that the
studios or the IP owners are connecting
with their fandoms and that the fandoms
are able to connect with the stories
they love so that is something I hope to
do now for the rest of my career so this
was not a long journey per se but it
well I mean I'm old so it is a semi long
journey but I started I was really
really lucky I started in TV production
went to school for it uh worked on game
shows wrote for game shows but what I
ended up falling into was in in 86 to
'92 I worked in post production and when
I worked in post production this was the
beginning of Max use in post production
and new Avid technology which was
originally called Video Toaster and I
was hooked on computers and digital and
and as soon as I was as soon as I was
online I was in what was called uset
groups and chat rooms for X Files and
for um like Buffy once it came along but
X Files was one of my very very first as
well as aliens so I was doing that as a
fan and then I was working TV production
so throughout the years what I got to do
is I got to work on production agency
side so I worked and did some of the
first websites and uh online games for
video game companies so I got to do Gran
Torino and uh Spyro a whole bunch of
really fun things that missed and then I
got to to do a whole bunch of early
digital websites and games for TV
production and films so some of my first
ones that I worked on were minority
reports master and Commander things like
that and what I became very very excited
about was that I got to do sci-fi and I
got to do and I worked on production
company and Studio side and agency side
and I ended up at
Fox as a
consultant and as a producer consultant
and nobody I'm literally in a meeting
one day and this is
2002 and someone says you know does
anybody know about this stardy title
show series whatever because we're going
to be doing all of the post broadcast
and we're working with MGM does anybody
want to do this and of course there's
silence now I'm new at the time and I'm
like I'll do it I want to do it and they
said why and I said because I've been
watching it so hey and then that
literally was the beginning of me taking
all sci-fi geek titles at or any kind of
phandom titles or franchises at Fox
because at the time in digital marketing
and digital producing so we did digital
content not just digital marketing we
created digital content nobody wanted
these
titles at that time people my age
weren't quite in charge yet so you
didn't quite have the Kevin Fey you
didn't have the people that grew up with
it in charge we were just starting to
get to that point as soon as that
started to happen then was accepted and
everything was great but so I got all
the aliens franchises The Good the Bad
and the
Ugly all
predators uh all of Buffy Angel
Firefly um Serenity and then I got James
Bond which was amazing and that was that
was super special to work on that and it
was then I moved almost entirely into TV
so I had all of mgm's TV sci-fi geek all
of Fox's sci-fi geek and there it was
funny animation was thrown into that
because again nobody wanted to do it
okay so I'll do family gu and Simpsons
not so what that meant was when I say
just made harr's
day so you know what that meant by doing
is is I was producing with
agencies digital content digital
marketing
and creating and getting to be on set or
working with fuzzy door to get original
content so that was what I got to do and
it was so early nobody was paying any
attention to us now we got like a buck
99 and a cup of coffee for a budget but
also the trade-off for that was if I
went to someone and said hey my friend
Scott who runs this new digital agency
they've come up with this really cool
chat functionality and we want to do
something for um the two horror movies
that we're doing they said sure why not
we don't care and if I wanted to do a
database for Stargate and we wanted to
do a flash game for Stargate they said
sure we don't care so I got to do the
first game first Flash game for staring
online things like that so that was that
was amazing and as I'm doing
that as a fan but as a producer I'm
realizing that the
relationship what you guys do didn't
exist there was no relationship with
fans none you had some very special
shows that tried to make that effort
Chris Carter was one Chris Carter would
show up in the uset groups in a chat
rooms but that was unusual and you know
I know he is the uh the Creator who will
not be named for Buffy Firefly Etc but
he did the same thing he showed up he
went into chat rooms on his own he came
online and talked with some of our
fandoms when I had online
events that was unusual and what I was
realizing was that I was working with
Sony and fox and MGM and they had what's
called a window window which is here's
the release date and six weeks prior
maybe three months prior and two weeks
after is our window for marketing and
content and after that we don't care
we're not going to waste money which
means all of us sustaining gate World
sustain those relationships was on us
was on fans and so I started to see
that what I wanted to do especially as
internally at Fox and MGM and at the
studios digital marketing and digital
content became
traditional and when that happens it
starts to get very rigid and very
restricted and very curated in not a
great sense and so in 2015 I'm like love
you guys I'm out of here I'm going to go
back to full-time Consulting and do
fandom and that's where I've been for
the past holy crap that's eight years so
that's what I've been doing and I work
with I worked with Stargate for three
years on Stargate command and I helped
develop all of that and then I've done
um I did a whole bunch of really cool
shows with consumer products and with
light storm and now with authors too so
that's what I do amazing so if we'll
talk about St a little bit because it's
what we like to talk about on this
channel for one we did wonder whether
there might be something announced today
and you know that I think that crunching
noise is me actually
oh me I'm
sorry um
but it doesn't look like it's going to
be today but do you do you have I know
you maybe I don't have inside knowledge
on this but what is your good feeling
when do you think it might happen
well I think it could happen any time I
I think honestly that the reason the
announcement didn't happen today is
because of the SAG after breakdown um
yesterday and Thursday
uh sag negotiating committee was
disappointed in what uh and PTP came
back with it wasn't bad but you know
it's the typical and PTP was super proud
of the residuals and the percentage that
they came back with I mean you know sag
is saying one % this I don't know what
are you g to do you're G to go down to0
five% so I think what happened is Amazon
looked at that and NGM looked at that
and said you know what we don't want to
be in the middle of this we don't want
to be making an announcement for
something really amazing in the middle
of this because I know that there are
two other company of I'm working with
who postponed their announcements for
the same reason so I'm guessing
speculating that it is the same I think
that once that settles and look once we
get into November I don't think they're
going to make an announcement there
are two groups of thought right now what
you guys know there is the they're going
to just do this to do it and move
forward or they're going to dedicate
serious creative time and energy to it I
honestly can't tell you which way it is
MGM wants to dedicate time and energy
and creative Creative Energy to it they
are adamant about but the way that and
GM has split its creative decision
making is that all franchises and
existing um IP went to Amazon creative
Studios all new creative content like
handmade tale great new world upload
that stayed with MGM and under the
creative direction of Rob Haw and those
guys
but the others the franchises aren't in
their control so that's there's there
that's a weird dichotomy it is very
weird to not take the the industry
information and knowledge that they've
got and not bring it with you
but 18 months worth of development work
that they did towards
with They carried on you know look we
all know especially all of us being
varying degrees of sports fans right the
new football manager comes in and says I
don't care how good you were I don't
care that you came from Barcelona I'm
getting rid of everybody and I only want
my guys on this I get that but
to
completely deny some people who are on
the mm side who have incredible Stargate
knowledge Bank feels weird that's where
you get to the what you guys have
reported on the internal uh push me pull
you that's happening even within Amazon
so not only do you have the Amazon
versus MGM issues but then you've got
the within Amazon issues and then you
know they lost a couple of people in the
past year lost that I was really
disappointed left because they would
have been
phenomenal leaders to kind of write this
ship for this particular franchise but
not just this one because I worked on a
whole bunch of MGM franch and I would
have loved to have seen what they could
have done with Robocop and some of the
other ones but I think what's probably
going to happen and this is me guessing
is that once we get into November it
won't happen until the beginning of the
year unless they want to just kind
of shove it aside and have it not be a
big announcement I I can't imagine
they'd want to do it that way but we get
too close to our Thanksgiving it's it's
not going to happen yeah I'm being told
this probably just going to be a press
release it it won't be more than that
now they've missed all of the
opportunities they had to make a big
deal out of it yep well they could just
wait till WonderCon frankly but because
WonderCon would be an amazing
announcement they could have done London
MCM which would have been great um they
could do fedcon so I think there are
windows here but I you know it's all I'm
hearing is that it's it's kind of a [__]
that it is not organized and delineated
the way it could have been for some
super legitimate reasons like the strike
and people leaving that you know you
can't do anything about that but the
rest of it is you know it's it's
conscious decisions and I don't know if
that's just internal Dynamics and
frustrations and you know I still give
Jen Sala now it's not under Nick pepper
anymore which is too bad but because I
love him he does Great Stuff with
development but I know it's not easy you
get something like MGM and you've got 10
active franchises one of which is
partially owned and very vocal about his
non-ownership of the rocky franchise you
know those are the things that that you
have to deal with immediately
politically and I and I get that but and
then you've got your own Amazon things
that are you know genv launching and
everything else it's just for us as
Stargate fans it's beyond frustrating it
is it is the the cycle that we go
through and have been through with MGM
for decades of the yes no yes we will oh
[__] no it's not going to happen you
know and that just gets Beyond tiresome
I think the gator and the general
Community is starting to get bored of
this now and I think to be honest cidre
might be a big part of that because
we've been talking about it so often so
long now well but the things yeah you
know you know the thing is is that but
it's not that you know I was talking to
Darren about this too G well it's not
like these haven't been legitimate oh my
God we think it's going to happen and
and sure there's lots of things that you
guys have heard that were dead ends okay
fine but there were at least I would say
four legitimate okay it's going to
happen moments in the past year and a
half and each one of those for varying
degrees of which I think is legit the
other I think is [__] is that it
just didn't happen I think the strike
and sdcc was completely legit I get that
the other three times I think it was
internal politics and that's really hard
for a fan to say shrug and say okay no
problem I'm okay with
this
I a big problem they had that it seemed
to be while from when the sale went
through to when it was finalized
Amazon allowed MGM to believe that they
were going to basically continue to
exist as a separate entity a bit like
what fox does with Disney they they are
still act as a studio and then as soon
as the S went through they just went no
you're' being absorbed and MGM was
behaving as if they were gonna they were
contining are there are parts of MGM
though that do exist as its own shingle
I think you're I think you're right
there's a huge problem so you know all
of those murges happened at the same
time and of course nobody talks about
the AT&T and bner brothers that was
happening at the same time and had the
antitrust suit against it but all of
those happened at the same time I don't
know how the AT&T Warner Brothers thing
flies under the radar and these two are
the ones that get all the news but you
know you're looking at what Bob Iger
wants to do now or at least what's rued
and what I'm being told is going to
happen which is either box is going to
be resold or he's just going to chunk it
off in the
yard there are
I think that the the merger with Disney
and fox actually was pretty standard so
there were certain things that were
written into those contracts like search
light Gracie which is Simpsons those all
continue to operate under their own
shingle and they do their own thing Fox
broadcasting is its own thing it's not
owned by Disney so it was really just
20th Century Fox 20th films 20th
TV and FX FX and FXX currently still
operate under John lingraph as its own
Silo so that's fine but everything else
if you try to find any of the titles
that I worked on whether it's you know
aliens or Predators or even you know
bond is different but any of those it's
very hard to find those you can't find
them on Disney plus sometimes they're
there sometimes there's not there's no
announcements but the people who worked
at Fox were given an opportunity to take
a package if they full-time employees
when the merge happened if you wanted to
go over it was two to three years before
they were told hey that's it and there's
still probably 20 to 25 people over at
Disney that were with Fox 20 um filmed
entertainment the the MGM Amazon to your
point was radically different normally
that would have been a 2 to threee
transition employees would have been
kept you would where there's
redundancies there are parts of MGM that
are 100% their own Rob Haws the creative
development Steve Stars they're all
their own shingles still MGM
Productions
but the rest of it's a
mess and and people weren't laid off per
se they were just absorbed to your point
and so contracts are just not taken up
anybody on a shter contract was just
yeah and and the redundancies still
exist so you've
got mgm's social and PR team and digital
marketing team they still exist which is
great except it's redundant to Amazon's
existing and they haven't absorbed those
content silos Amazon operates on
thematic content silos so if you're
sci-fi fantasy there's a whole Silo and
a whole team from top to bottom that
does that yeah that's not how that's not
how NGM works because it's a smaller
studio right it's one PR corporate press
Communications for all of their
franchises titles that whole thing same
with social and digital marketing so
Steven Bruno and all these guys who are
great and they they love what they do
with MGM they're still there but they're
redundant to some of the
Amazon there's not a clear path and I
think that that from an organizational
standpoint again I'm on the outside
looking in I'm not working for MGM
currently I don't know how that works
cleanly it just doesn't sound clean it
doesn't sound easy it doesn't sound like
uh like if I was still there and I
wanted to do some of the things we did
for Stargate command I don't even know
who I would pitch that
to do you think a lot of this is just
because the the merger was a little
messy I think they planned one thing
they went another way is this just them
still shaking out the management true
because I mean Amazon is still hiring
people they did just like a month ago
they hired a new head of theatrical
releases and manager for that yeah and
there you know Amazon's got its own
infrastructure issues that and I'm not
I'm not picking on them there isn't one
Studio One creative one streamer one
Haring production company that isn't
going through issues right now I I think
the only one I can name would be monkey
paw Productions and maybe couple of
others who are pretty clean and clear on
what they want in their Direction yeah
everybody else is struggling from the
top down bottom up they're all
struggling what's the tech what's the
screaming oh my God the strike how do we
handle this okay if we accept all of
this what does that mean now I have to
have guaranteed writers in my writer
room so and hear people like Taylor
Sheridan doing interviews saying I'm My
Own writer I'm My Own showrunner I don't
want to have forced writers teams in my
my writer room so you've got internal
issues nobody's clean right now so I
think you're right I think
that I think that the plan was good
because I was there when they started to
do their audit when Amazon started to do
the audit and it was fairly
hardcore standard mergers and
Acquisitions it was this was great this
is what we're going to do this is what
we have to hand over so I was working
with a girl named Kyla uh starer who was
running star get command by that time we
were the last two that turned off the
lights but everything that we handed
over was pretty standard for an audit
when there's a merger and acquisition
cool okay so we're thinking great you
know you'll use this you don't use it
whatever but we had a lot of unused
footage a lot of unused footage and Kyla
was trying to to have that convert to a
YouTube channel and a whole bit to
monetize it nothing and partially that
was because NGM wasn't going to make a
decision while waiting for for a actual
signed
contract with
Co that screwed everything and so again
like I said earlier there are excuses
for some of what's happened that were
real world issues coid strike cool but
Amazon banked during Co and
2021 and it seems to me outside looking
in that there were easier ways to do
this than how it went down and I'm not
the only one that thinks that that's
pretty much a general consensus with
entertainment industry experts with
business experts purchas and
Acquisitions experts to your point Jay
that there were better ways to handle
this to handle how the
NGM group departments divisions people
real people with real jobs got absorbed
or not and then how those franchises are
being handled I like I said I was
shocked that they're not taking
advantage of the font of knowledge for
these franchises on MD I mean
particularly as Amazon is a relatively
still a new studio I mean they are a
baby really they've only been
producing five years or something
they've only had their own Studios like
18 months well here's the thing thing
and this is I'm G to jump out and come
back and see if my microphone will
restart you to handle we got you I think
part of this is that any time in the
entertainment industry especially since
digital from 86 to 92 became a media
right a platform for us to deliver
content
on when you look at who were the
upstarts then those are the traditional
you know the man that's Google and
Facebook and Amazon for that matter but
the content delivery portions of these
companies are still kind of the upstarts
the streamers so Apple's been around but
their streaming and their content and as
a creative studio is still fairly new to
this industry they're adolescents so
when you're an adolescent what do you do
you do everything that's contrary to
what came before you think you know
better you think you know how to do it
better and that that's a pretty standard
cycle I mean if you look at anything in
the entertainment industry with content
with a new platform this is a pretty
standard cycle it's all going to come
out in the wash it it is all going to
figure out but in the meantime you've
got mergers and Acquisitions and
panicked and content and usually what's
happening during that type of upheaval
or change is that you have independent
content creators who say okay well I'm
not really worry about you guys I'm
going to do my own thing which is
exactly what's happened and what I keep
talking about what I'm what I am Bing
the drum about is people like yourselves
people that are creating new content new
access to
content you guys are going to be the
ones that bring us into whatever is
going to happen next yes Amazon and the
the BMS that are essentially the tent
holes of course they're still going to
exist they're going to be the
Distributors but but just like the rise
of the independent studios in the early
90s which came out of exactly the same
thing which was in the 80s all these
Studios got too big they got bloated
seriously bloated and what they were
creating was bloated content and so what
you ended up having in reaction to that
was a rise of independent content
creators who said you know what like
Robert Rodriguez I'm done with this I'm
gonna do my own thing I'm gonna create
my own digital Studio and that's what we
have right now I think our focus should
be on people like pengin in a Parker
thank you very much which I never say
right uh Panda isn't it I was I've
literally been saying that for so long
and now it's just stuck in my head but
Monkey popw Productions Pang Parker
Parker uh I know Reese rther Spen just
sold Sunshine but all of these smaller
production houses and let's be honest
Tik Tok and YouTube creation houses
are the ones to pay attention to they're
the ones that we should be looking at
for Innovation for technology for
Content Innovation for creativity it's
it's not that the big guys won't still
create great amazing things they will I
mean gen V is a kickass show but oh it's
so fun so fun I I know you do Jamie but
it's so fun the new episode was perfect
it is not for everybody I get it I got I
gen V and the invincibles better than
the boys um you know I'll watch anything
that they create but I I I got kind of
bored with the boys was like okay I get
it but Jen B to me is fascinating in
what it can bring to the table that is
reflective of what's going on in the
world and I love that I also love that
we're adapting lots and lots of cool
graphic novels and original content but
these guys aren't going to be the only
ones that do it that's I I think we need
to be looking at if you go over to web
Tunes the the original content that's on
there is unbelievable and so when you
hear people say oh well you know there's
nothing new well you're not trying hard
enough there is new content everywhere
and that's where I get excited that
we're in a new frontier no offense to
Stargate but part of the fatigue of the
will we or won't we has left me just
looking elsewhere and so I'm working
with sci-fi fantasy authors now which
I've never worked with authors directly
before it was always via the studio who
bought the property right so I've worked
with tons of authors and graphic
novelists but it was because the studio
had bought their IP now I'm getting to
work with authors before they've sold
their IP so it's you find new avenues to
go do really cool creative things when
things like Amazon and MGM butt heads
and come to a grinding halt look for new
stuff it it does it does feel like
they're just up bicker and children
arguing to be honest I've heard again
apparently there was um a discussion
literally within the last two weeks of
somebody Amazon sort of going to a
couple of people over MGM okay you keep
going on about Brad wri and doing a TV
series explain to us why and apparently
they had a meeting with slideshows and
stuff would loved to been a flying oh my
God okay so I heard the same thing and
all I kept thinking was and again I
heard it third hand so I'm glad you
heard the same thing because you know by
the time I hear it sometimes I'm like oh
did that really happen or was that just
you know wish fulfillment who knows but
I would have laughed my head off and
just been in absolute joy to see that
meeting like okay so like a graph this
is this is dgate with bre rat involved
and this is dgate with butting
though there's gate world and sidet trk
and get into the gate and fre fry short
and oh by the way you haven't paid any
attention to any of these but you know
it's you know the you know the the
rumors that that you and I have heard a
lot over the past two
years some of them I think are probably
accurate which is going back to I get it
creative Studios Amazon said we just
want to start new you know you guys
tried to do this and it didn't work and
it didn't work and it didn't work I
totally get that but what they don't
realize is the bottom line and Brad
talked about this two weeks ago with you
guys is that I got to work with him when
he was doing that pilot and with Rob
hawber and Chris ainger over at MGM who
were the ones who went to Brad and said
hey we really want to try to do this and
basically a lot of it came down to money
and
and I think what Amazon might not really
I I don't know historically I don't know
that they're looking at the fact that it
wasn't that the content was a burnout or
that it didn't have traction or that it
couldn't happen but there's context to
everything right I mean our origin
series was not great but the reason we
did it was because at the time it was
the only thing that we could get
approval was to create a story based on
the movie we didn't have approval at
that time even though it was an MGM
project to do something within the Brad
Wright universe so then we kill
ourselves to meet with Brad make sure
that he's okay we get the okay we start
doing meetings with Chris judge to do an
entire jafo story origin story and we
can't get the money for
it Brad wr's pilot we can't get the
money for it and I don't blame MGM for
that you're a small Studio you're not a
big Studio you do not have 15 or10
million per episode and we weren't
asking for that but it doesn't matter I
mean we made money on Catherine on
Origins but it wasn't enough to say okay
we can keep going and the biggest
problem was quite frankly is that MGM
was going to be sold so I don't you know
I don't know if people know but so Gary
Barber ran NGM for a long time and his
entire that's when he took it over when
it went into bankruptcy he came over
from spy glass which was his company his
financial company ran MGM for years and
his entire directive by the board was to
prep it for sale so I've been through
I've been through four five four or five
top management rotations in ownership at
MGM and
I loved Gary because he was realistic
you know you never I always knew where
we were if I pitch something he like
what the you talking about like okay
that's not gonna apply cool so with Gary
it was always bottom line now the beauty
of that was he was smart enough to
surround himself with really creative
people he's the bottom line guy
surrounds himself with creative people
he preps it for sale the board God Lov
them both sides had pros and cons I
don't fall to either side the board ends
up saying Gary comes to them in 20 18
whatever it was he left and says okay
I've got everything ready we're in the
block we've been in the block for three
years running we're ready let's do it
and the board
says we've got cold feet we really want
to keep the the studio going we think
the studio is amazing it's it's a
tradition let's do it let's stay and
here's like I'm out
you know you hired me to do this and now
you're you're doing this and what
followed was two and a half years of
decision by committee they all wanted
the right thing they all wanted the MGM
tradition but they were
hardcore this is a Hollywood tradition
we don't want this to be broken up and
they couldn't do it and when that
happened we were in the middle we had
just built this gorgeous platform and
that's when they decided to sell and so
the platform had to be shuttered we had
a fiveyear plan with a woman who was
amazing consultant who had put together
the fiveyear
plan and she had us in the black in five
years on Stargate command and we had
these two projects lined up with Chris
and with Brad I think we would have made
money sooner
but that was not their fault that was
okay good decisions try to do the right
thing wanted to keep this Hollywood
tradition this studio intact Gary Barber
had done all the right things that he
had been given the director to do nobody
is the bad guy in the story this is
normal business in Hollywood most people
have good intentions in Hollywood most
people want to do cool content make a
great movie make a great
series sure you have the bean counters
that are in charge but if you've got a
good you encounter like Gary Barber who
surrounds himself with creative people
you can get amazing stuff John lingraph
is a perfect example of kind of a
unicorn he was extremely smart on the
business side and he recognizes his
creative Talent that's unusual you don't
always get that and I think all of this
unfortunately Stargate becomes the
sacrificial land and when you were
talking earlier about the fatigue I
think it's because you have one thing
after another that were just the nature
of the outside things that were
happening and then some bad
[Music]
decision Peng we mentioned penguin and
AP parka earlier and um the the company
own by um hwk gby which is the greatest
name ever and Mark Fergus um I've not
heard anything solid about p park in a
fin
year I did hear no I definitely heard uh
about three months ago or gosh I guess
now would be five months ago right
before the writer strike um they had
submitted another updated version of
what they wanted to do but everything
came to a halt so the last thing I heard
was during the strike there was a um and
again you know this is this is rumor so
I don't I don't have any verification on
this but is that whether or not their
their development contract would be
reviewed was up and because the strike
was on it wasn't going to be
decided so I don't know what's happened
since yeah the last thing I heard was
that that was being negotiated I think
that was the last con there was or some
negotiations going on with what and that
was at the point they were still oning
about what to do yeah would it be a
movie would it be a TV series and I
think that was pretty much the last
thing I heard was it got to a point of
was like tell me what you want right or
let's just put it on plug in it but it
sounds like things did develop after
that then which
is I just don't know what happened
post beat my speak my
microphone Post
strike I think that a lot of people
wanted to kind of clear the deck
and I don't know you know I I do know
like you and I both heard about the
meeting that happened I guess it's
almost two weeks ago now atgm where
they're saying here's Brad white here's
the cannon this is how this works here's
the Stargate Universe um I don't know if
that happened because there's a change
of mind about whether or not it should
be a movie first and then a series or a
series I that I have no idea and that's
you know I hope to find out more in the
next couple weeks but you
know I do think it's possible they've
changed their from what I heard was
during the strikes they did and Amazon
and apparently all the studios pretty
much did the same thing it's go right
we're gonna audit everything yeah
everything regardless of what position
it's at we've got we're in P for six
months let's about everything so I do
think it's possible they could have
changed their minds even if they did go
as far as maybe even putting this
starting to think about sets in I think
they could have just
gone had gotten to some point because we
know for a fact that they were going to
try to make an announcement at sdcc so
that I mean obviously if they had gotten
to some point then what they did post I
have no idea I mean that's where I'm
hoping to find out some more information
in the next couple weeks I it's you know
I don't think they want anything to do
with us that we're part of the Old Guard
but it doesn't stop me from raising my
hand and saying you know I apparently
have a very thick skin um from saying
hey I'm here I you know if you want
something you should be talking to these
guys that are over here like Rob hawber
and David and Darren but you know I
don't I don't know right now at all
everything that I knew was up through
the writer strike everything I know now
is 100% rumor so I'm hoping to catch up
next week with some people because
nobody wanted to talk during the strike
so I'm hoping to catch up with some
people next week and see what the state
of the union is basically and you know
who knows it's
yeah it's it's it really is the same for
me I just keep hearing um things through
third hand and and once and and some
some of it makes sense I still think
there's still some bitter grapes
knocking around with some people and I
hear
some definitely some bitter grapes I and
I don't understand why exactly but
whatever it it is
uh you would think with a brand new
studio and brand new people that
especially when you've got someone like
Michael Wright who's head of NGM plus
bang in the drum for Stargate oh thought
he was gonna get it on MGM plus I mean I
I love Michael I am I supporter of him
Furious when they said it was gonna be a
movie apparently oh my God and and and
but but you know a lot of Amazon's new
business models in the creative studios
are following that
idea I talked about this I think with
you before or with Darren I can't
remember but Amazon has with the Citadel
a business model that they're very
excited about and oh yeah and you talked
about this too so I think I talked about
it after you talked about stole it from
totally look I love I love this idea I
think a it's a no-brainer you should be
absolutely capitalizing on International
I work internal
for 20 years and I I absolutely love it
and we not you two but we domestic quote
unquote domestic are idiots we we
pretend that somehow our box office or
our series streaming numbers are the
ones that count they don't for years I
would go into meetings and I go okay so
I know this isn't going to make sense to
you but you know fill in the blank show
is huge in India and we've got our
biggest numbers in India and you guys
are idiots that are not letting me do
this why would we spend money if it's
all I me literally why would we spend
money if you're showing us that it's
already doing well how's that for
backwards loog logic it's already
getting billion
people a billion and a half
now yeah just because we got you know 18
million viewers there's three 00 million
more that we could be going after but
sure let's just go with what's in hand
whatever so global international
business model that Amazon is doing is
huge and this is this is okay I I'm a
nerd for this business stuff but Netflix
is the one who spent years building the
global model years doing this model y
Amazon comes in as an e-commerce now
from an e-commerce standpoint they had
absolutely built a Global business model
for e-commerce that doesn't translate
necessarily to content so they come in
and everybody in 2019 at CES it was
hilarious everybody's like oh what's you
know how's Amazon gonna capture and I'm
thinking because they're not idiots they
look at Netflix and they go Netflix has
basically macheted the path for us we're
just going to follow their which is
exactly what they did now what I love
about what Jen Sala and it's I I don't
think it was her I think it was her
predecessor that came up with this but I
don't know for sure the Citadel model is
spoton for starting it would be amazing
I don't care if they start with a movie
and then do a series who cares what
would be amazing is if you do what the
Citadel is doing which is there's a
universe that's
Global and we're going to share the
production costs across the biggest
countries like France and Germany Spain
Japan Jaan Brazil so those were the top
five territories when it was big I just
went and looked at the numbers recently
the numbers Japan is no longer um South
Korea is we're sted uh Brazil is still
for Latin America France and Germany are
still top for Europe sorry guys and uh
Spain and UK come up behind that okay so
go to production companies in those in
those countries in those territories and
have them do a story that is inherent
and organic to them about the Stargate
franchise how cool would that be and it
there's a production company in Spain
called CAD Deus who is paying people to
come shoot there literally Spain wants
to spend 54 billion dollar over the next
five years bringing production to
Spain okay why are we not shooting there
so how cool would that be as apply this
business model you're already doing to
Stargate I
think they've got I think they've just
built a studio in Spain they've got one
in Brazil yes I think they've got a big
one they've got another big one in South
America somewhere but they've got thing
all over and I'm sure the Hackman group
are doing exactly the same they're in 60
something countries in it exactly
and the hman group very strongly linked
with Amazon so imagine the varied
locations we'd get if they did it
worldwide and we weren't just in Canada
in the
trees can you imagine aliens on the
river temps or something right hey you
know Nigeria is dying for new production
and they make over I think the last was
$13 billion doll a year people have no
idea in and Hollywood's the fastest
growing film place in the world right
the BBC film all sorts of things we we
got strong big British links with
Nigeria they all speak
English yeah it's crazy the US you know
not political but we're very arrogant
and
so think as well that Amazon are
thinking long term let's cut sagaa and
the wga and all these people out if we
produce abroad where the act as things
aren't membered we don't have this
problem every three years oh okay
timeout so no because here's how that
goes horribly wrong so I love you but no
no no you're the you're the experts I'm
just sense to me no no I'm not an expert
this is this is opinion at this point I
I
absolutely support the stripes and one
of the reasons why I think it's
dangerous to take the international
model without supporting your workers is
that it goes wrong every time there
there is in hist in history historically
speaking every every e an industry you
exploit workers worldwide even if it's a
minor exploitation because and of course
the excuse is always well they want to
do this well of course they do because
they want to work if you do that it
comes back and bites you on the ass so
the best way to do this is to export sag
after and wga and DGA rules
as it fits within because quite frankly
Bollywood just went through a major
overhaul where their actors are looking
to unionize so it's already going to
happen so what you should be doing is
negotiating with these that they have
their own unions it shouldn't I'm I'm
with you that it shouldn't be sag after
or wga just like Canada's got its own
not I mean the British unions very early
on went we're going to stick with we'll
we'll we shown our solidarity with s
after something and did the same thing
absolutely and we did the same when uh B
went on strike but it shouldn't be us in
charge it should be India should have
its own actor Union I think I think it
does now but the beauty of that is it's
still cheaper to shoot in those
countries even if you're matching what
their day rates are or should be it's
still cheaper even in the USA though I
mean filming in Georgia and places like
this they have massive tax break and
everything else I I just if I was in
charge of Amazon at the moment I would I
would have in the back of my head can we
try to limit our
um right so if they go and strike again
how do we keep working and that might be
one one way of doing it is making it as
International as possible so then your
business model isn't shut down
completely I think that that is the
answer I think that you thinking more
from a management standpoint right and a
fan standpoint from a worker standpoint
the problem with that is that you lose
leverage
obviously one of the issues I think that
they run into with the Citadel model now
the Citadel model was pitched by its
production company they put it together
but one of the issues that they're going
to run into is that there's a strike
here it affects regardless if the unions
are supportive in other countries or not
now I think the one that's coming out in
2024 is France or Spain I can't remember
which one and I know that Brazil is
shooting so they went ahead regardless
of the strike y the problem with that
was that the showrunners here in the US
couldn't officially do anything with
them so there there are barriers to that
that are going to happen no matter what
I
think it you know there's there's a
different conversation about and I'm
sure all of us are watching shows from
other countries that are developed in
those countries that have nothing to do
with our US market that's a whole
another conversation I know that Amazon
and Netflix as you know Netflix has
purchased a a huge portion of South
Korean
content quids wor of investment yeah and
they've got a fiveyear contract that
expires in 202 five or six I think and I
think they'll renew it unless South
Korea says oh you know what we're going
to do it elv but you know that was
brilliant and Amazon ironically was
doing that before Netflix just not as
well so when Amazon first started its
Prim video it went and bought content
from around the world because that's
what it had to do it wasn't creating its
own content at the moment so they
actually kind of created that particular
business model but Netflix capitalized
on it and did it better at first what
Amazon's trying to do now that I
appreciate is they're trying to create a
new business model that is completely
original now some we haven't talked
about at all is Apple Apple's over here
doing its own thing creating worldwide
Global content with production companies
from Norway and Sweden and Spain and
japanes slow horses on Apple is one of
the best shows I've seen in a very very
long time I've just got through the
first season it's amazing it's amazing
and it's
that's beautiful I love that What's um
what is frustrating about Apple is it's
a bit of a gated community
so once you're in Apple app right but
it's very hard to break into that as a
creative to get into that to to pitch to
them as hard I've had one pitch get in
front of them in like 10 years so it's
just very hard to get in that once
you're in holy cow that's amazing you
know you could bring them anything and
they'll they'll give it a try some D has
done very well out of their relationship
with oh please I mean it's Apple's
brilliant now part of the problem I've
got with them is that nobody talks about
how they've kind of been problematic at
the negotiating table because they
basically don't care there was a point
where they were going to negotiate their
own contract with W pardon me with the
wga and they were just like yeah I we
don't really give a crap about Netflix
and Amazon and we sure as [__] don't get
care about the studios so why don't we
just go over here and do our own thing
and they the negotiating committee
started to do that and they realized
well this is not a good precedent you
know we'll do a24 and give some
exemptions to some other production
companies ping on par was one but we're
not GNA this is a studio we're not going
to do this so I think I think all of
it's fascinating obviously sorry I've
talked a lot I love this stuff I
absolutely love the business it's fun to
listen well I've always been T Amon
behave like businesses rather than
Studios and so apparently a lot of the
more traditional like Warner Brothers
and stuff just I feel like they're
banging the head against the W when it
comes to Amazon whenever they have
negotiate with them they they don't
behave like a traditional Studio like
a and you know it was worse before they
hired Jen Sala and Nick pepper and those
guys and um Jen sala's predecessor I'm
blanking on the name um and and the
theatrical position has now rotated
through three different people in the
past two years so they haven't got that
down yet um but yeah they
don't they acted like an e-commerce
assembly line at first then they
realized that didn't work when they
created Amazon creative Studios separate
from Prim video it was all just under a
Prime video at first creative Studios
was their first foray into okay we get
it as much as we want to buff the system
there are things that we have to follow
as an entertainment creative studio and
that's the same thing Apple went through
Apple tried to do it like they created
their watches and their phones and that
didn't work and so when they created
their own creative Studio that was much
better so I think what Warner Brothers
is going through is a morality tale it
is fascinating to watch what one of
others is going through with DC with its
content there are huge wins obviously
with Barbie and Etc but it's almost like
it's in spite of themselves like they're
getting wins because you've got some
really good people at Warner Brothers
who pick really good content but it's
almost in spite of the crap that's going
on
internally I mean they've destroyed HBO
pretty much I mean Max is how do you
have such a
well-known Elon Musk turning Twitter to
X is the only thing that I can think of
that compares to how Warner Brothers has
ruined
HBO
um I mean they seem to be trying to
change direction in the last 12 months
and refocusing on their strengths so
orner Brothers I think will be we'll see
how it goes but but why you get HBO I
mean just weird it it's the recognizable
name yeah and you change it to it's
their face brand you're super quiet
dude yeah I know I'm just
listening shut up
Matt okay it up Matt come on you know
you want
to sorry Brad's telling him to shut up
is he
literally his favorite moment
that was a brilliant night I absolutely
adored that night I I I
would I would love Brad wght to get
involved in this what what what do you
think again this is coming from you gut
I know but do you actually think it
would be sensible for them to get Brad W
involved some way do you think they
would or do you think this is just going
be penguin in the park of fresh
blood I honestly at this point I don't
know for a long time I thought
very encouragingly that they were going
to at least bring on Brad as a
consultant I don't think it's going to
happen now I think they should just as a
consultant I mean I I don't think quite
frankly from talk BR I don't think Brad
wants to do it at this point but I think
that I think it's bad business I mean in
terms of I don't think he wants to write
and do new show I mean he's just doing
all new stuff now right he's doing
really cool new projects and he's
pitching and he's got all these
development projects it would be in a
way going backwards right and that's
that's not to say that he wouldn't he
obviously loves it because he's got the
um investment with the companion and he
loves sci-fi he loves starting he loves
talking about it and he obviously spends
time with it
but I think it would be and I'm not
speaking as a fan as a Creator as a
producer I think it would be insane to
not have them as a consultant because
again it's a library of knowledge that
does really multiple goals achieves
outcomes multiple outcomes number one he
knows the cannon why would you even in a
reboot start something without knowledge
of what came before you always do you
always spend time withing before either
not to repeat and be redundant or if
you're going to reboot and do it from
scratch to do it right so why wouldn't
you have them at minimum as a consultant
for the cannon that he created and then
bring the rest of them on as consultants
I mean this is not complicated I am sure
poop and Joe and Paul would be happy or
even Jonathan glasner to come on and
give time to them a a delineated time
and say this is what we were thinking
here's the Brain Trust let's put this on
the table and we're out that's it I mean
then you can say
consultant with or you know the um or ma
McKinnon technical consultant I mean you
should have these people on your initial
pre-production at minimum as a
producer that's not as a fan that's just
a No Greater to me it's what Star Trek
did they brought Rod Roden Brian because
they wanted his name on the thing you
know
that's and um it's to me bizar major
reaction in in my estimation of going
back
to I'm the new manager clear the decks I
don't want to use the same assistants I
don't want the same trainers I don't
want any of the same coaches it all
needs to be new people I I I have never
in sports thought that was particularly
smart you don't get rid of everybody you
keep the people who have institutional
knowledge uh you don't have to keep the
people that didn't do it right mhm your
opinion but you certainly keep the
people who have institutional knowledge
and that's the part that feels so wrong
with this that
is just a I mean again it's not I'm not
speaking as a fan as a producer if I was
brought into something the first thing I
would do is go to the people who created
it so you know the perfect example is X
Files you're not going to go do X Files
without Chris Carter or Frank spot
that's insane
it doesn't mean that you have them write
it you don't have to have them do it
from scratch but at minimum they would
be your consultants and here's what's
fascinating when that's come up at
Disney it's not even a question it's of
course we have them so I'm really
slightly no very confused and surprised
that very smart people seem to be
resisting bringing Brad on as a
consultant that seems to be the easiest
way to do it and here's the second
reason that's smart you will have
guaranteed there are last number 350
some odd thousand active Stargate fans
online around the world right now there
are up to three
million inactive or casual fans online
for a show that hasn't been on in
forever and is a 30y old franchise sleep
been giing a
Sci-Fi I mean come on why would you not
bring the guy who can bring you at
minimum
300,000
guaranteed people to watch your first go
around even if they it I I was thinking
the exact same thing it's not just the
knowledge that he's going to bring it's
the it's the very fact that the fact
that he's
involved fans are going to recognize
that and go oh it's actually the same
sort of project it's not a reboot it's
not it's not something completely
different and it's not going to
incentivize people to watch look I this
is something I don't think I've even
shared this David know
is so when we started Stargate
command I was brought on in 2015 2016 to
MGM to start the initial conversations
of doing want have been
stud and it was originally just to help
sell
uh obtainment so you know digital
downloads all that create new content
David was going to create new audio
track uh I'm sorry new audio
commentaries so for instance seasons 1
through 4 don't have director
commentaries audio commentaries so he
wants to do
that so we're talking with the powers at
B at MGM and we said well okay we're
going to call Brad and they they said
well why would you talk to
Brad he said well because if we're going
to start to do something that's a new
project and of course it wasn't called
stra command at that point we should be
bringing brat in and we were told oh
yeah yeah yeah okay we'll we'll
contact what ended up happening was that
two people in particular in a particular
division without any direction God Lov
when they were trying to take initiative
reached out to Martin gal and not to
Brad and when they did that this is a
small do they not know how small this
community is
so of course Martin calls BR immediately
and says dude why' they call me and
legitimately Brad was very frustrated
and very angry and it took a lot
of time and consideration and making
sure Chris ainger who was the president
went directly to Brad and said I'm sorry
this was not the way we should have
handled it this is how we want to do it
and after a lot
of genuine sincere from the heart okay
this is not what we meant to do Brad
tentatively said okay I'll have some
meetings with you
guys so why knowing that that happened
historically before why would you do
that again because once we got Brad on
board as a consultant to start a command
I instantly had we had 140 some OD
thousand or more than that 180,000
subscribers when we when we finish the
first 70,000 came because of the
announcement that Brad was
Consulting and Chris because Chris was
on the was on the panel with us made the
announcement
but that I mean we had 70,000
immediately within a
week so why would you not look at that
historically and say you have pilots and
shows that don't have that many viewers
on your pilot episode on your
streaming you know they don't release
those numbers but they're they're not in
the millions it's not you're not looking
at 1.3 million in your first go around
it's it takes a couple of weeks to build
up to a million 1.3 is usually your the
threshold that you want to look at so
why would you not look historically at
what didn't work what was wrong what
what we did that we made a mistake okay
and here's how how it got corrected why
would you not follow the same idea well
Amazon has their own precedent set
already with rings of power contacting
Peter Jackson and then just kind of
ghosting him as well I mean it's like
well and what's not encouraging about
that and that is a great parallel is the
seeming disrespect to the creators to
the original creators of this fans see
that yep and I again the
the blindness to and this is why I do
what I do now the blindness to how much
power fans have is insane to me it is
the conversations that I am still having
with production companies with
Distributors with Studios that I was
having 20 years ago just makes my head
explode I should not be having to say to
somebody okay hey so this is great thank
you so much I love this campaign so um I
I've got a strategy and a road map for
US post relase so that we keep this
relationship and not just maintain it
but sustain and grow it nurture it oh
why would we do that just had this
conversation a month ago why would we do
that Jenny we don't need to do that it's
a franchise that we just say it and
everybody comes I mean it was basically
their version of if we build it they
will come and I don't care about the
rest yeah that's not true anymore that
we we've proved that in the last last
two years how many movies have gone to
the cinema and bombed who thought
Indiana Jones was gonna bomb that badly
no it you can't make presumptions
anymore that just because well and
that's that goes back to our
conversation about the rise of
independent creation and creatives and
artistic and content and you know I
everybody gets up in arms about using
content but I'm not really sure and I
should probably talk to one of my artist
friends about why that is such a deal
but um you know in digital it's been
called content for 20 years in the sense
that content is the umbrella description
of anything that is created to be put
online good bad and different within
that then you talk about artists and
scripts and pilots and series and films
but it's all content I mean we're not
it's not a dismissive term and I think
that the rise of people like yourself
and people who are creating you know
beautiful iPhone films on a budget and
getting enough distribution I mean I've
got a really good friend she's oh uh
Rebecca from 35 short she's independent
producer and director and a writer and
she you know took time but they they
have made and I can't wait till she can
tell everybody a kickass independent
film like amazing so you've got people
doing their own content saying you you
know what I don't care about you guys I
don't need
to well even at a bigger level like the
creators out right now and they filmed
that on what was it Sony like 450s 4500
something like that I don't remember the
exact model but yeah it's not a red
camera it's not some giant expensive
camera no you can do a lot more with a
lot less and it's it's fascinating to me
that SPAC just had another interview I
mean I'm sorry but it's such a it's such
a generational you know I love him but
he's literally the cranky grandpa on the
porch you know yelling get off my lawn
you repar rates it's it's just so weird
to me that someone who is one of the
ones that created in reaction to in the
70s and in the 80s he created
independent film in reaction to the
bloated Insanity right so why are you
not supporting this great other things
now I get it when he's looking at Marvel
and DC films and he says you know those
are bloated big films but there's a
place for everything I I don't know why
that we get this either or concept of um
and okay so this is my own thing I was a
film major originally and I couldn't
handle the preciousness of the film
major I couldn't handle the literally I
made a film um about a documentary about
Texas football and comparing it to
Cowboys and
uh you know it did well but it didn't do
as well I lost to the guy I [__] you not
who shot in black and white and the
entire thing was a poem was gorgeous but
it was in black and white and it was a
rose not making this up losing its
petals with blood and red dripping that
was the entire film and that one and I'm
sitting there going I can't I just can't
with this stuff that's just a scene in
Beauty and the Beast
like it was I'm not kidding this was the
entire the whole
audience that was so and then of course
they're all applying some deep
philosophical thing to it their own
right yeah oh this is representative of
the decay of capitalism like oh Jesus
okay I'm out so that's when I went to TV
and I love TV production I think that
what we're looking at right now because
to me YouTube and social is the natural
pression of TV that's me that's you know
my background and that's my progression
I look at what's happening on Tik Tok
and I'm like this is the best thing ever
I just want to look and see who who are
new creators who's making something fun
I go on YouTube and I just look for
something fun I go on Twitch and I just
go look for something fun I mean David
blue David hulet and again you know
those are Stargate actors but I follow
them because they do fun content and
it's David huet is completely his own
thing with back Bandit so you you look
at new creators what they're doing and
they're old young in
between why would we not look for new
cont like that for
S yeah I think they must know this I
mean obviously we had a couple of emails
from MGM um I know anything for a couple
weeks but and they seem to be trying to
reach out knowing that okay if we're
going to talk about Stargate we're going
to need these couple of channels on on
our side because like what um what
Harris mentioned earlier the rings of
power pom there's a lot of negativity
about rings of power well before it ever
came out yeah and they seem to
definitely want to avoid that but it
seems to me that they're getting all
advice because um I have one of the
people I speak to works for one of the
larger sort of like PR marketing oh yeah
that's what you said yeah so they were
like sort of advising them do this do
this do this and then banging their
heads against the wall because it's just
say that they're not listening no got
differents
and you got different divisions so the
Sci-Fi uh fantasy division that just
hired a new person in charge of fandom
I'm blanking on what her name is um
they're probably the ones that reached
out to you quite frankly because they're
paying
attention they're there to develop the
audience keep the audience keep the
fandom do things that are like the boys
I mean the the boys and genv are
probably in invincibles are their best
uh or most successful camp CS because
what they done is looped fans in pulled
in asked them to create content opened
that door not then uh gated community
about it so that's brilliant However if
those divisions aren't cross
functionally talking to each other which
happens at a lot of Studios then what
you've just described is going to happen
your PR marketing agency is an outside
agency Amazon has a tendency even at
Crea Studios to be very weird about how
they deal with their outside vendors
their outside agencies they hire them
for their expertise and then they don't
necessarily listen to them so you
probably got contacted by an
internal group The fandom group but then
are they having cost functional meetings
with the production group or with MGM no
probably not not yet so they're out in
advance which is fantastic they've
contacted you and Darren and they
they've done that Outreach okay cool but
where's the backup from the production
from marketing from it's not
there
yeah just G around in the circle again
goes when gonna happen and it's sort of
like we it's genuinely it wouldn't
surprise me if it happened in the next
hour and it wouldn't surprise me if it
happened in February no I with you
absolutely I mean we could end this and
there's an announcement amazing we could
end this mons from now still not an
announc we we were literally saying
before we started the show it's going to
happen when me and Jay are in
bed 100% I'm GNA wake up to a load of
messages and I'm going to have missed it
and um there's been nothing I'm checking
on their their website there's nothing
my my phone doesn't come off do not
disturb until 9:00
am. so I'm not so I'm just going to miss
it completely and that day not until 5:
p.m. yeah we got an email a couple of
weeks ago when it looked like something
may happening it turned out it was
something else but um and you just got I
just got a message off him going have
you seen your emails 10 night calm down
well it gets and it gets you all excited
right so I got uh I got a text from
Michael Brown I think or somebody who
used to be the CMO at NGM last week oh
wait did you here and of course
immediately I think it's Stargate and it
wasn't it was you know something else
and I always that's why I need you oh my
God wait did we hear about Stargate and
he's like no we've got a whole
production thing going I'm like oh okay
great cool but it it is what my anytime
anybody that was connected to Stargate
texts me I get all excited thinking oh
that was it this is going to be it who
knows who know I honestly that is my
shrug and who knows is my default answer
now
yeah yeah we'll see well if it's not
today I'm hoping it's at La Comic-Con in
December because I go to that every year
so fingers cross oh wait so we have to
see each other I've got two boo at
ComiCon this year oh oh well yeah yeah
I'll be there all right awesome probably
be there in one of these shirts in one
of those
days take your phone yeah there you go
we got a video
SED Cleo's going to have my company I'm
going to have a lounge like a coffee
Lounge but then one of my clients were
doing a huge immersion Booth it's going
to be really cool it's a whole sci-fi
fantasy Booth it's a ship super cool so
just DM me and we'll figure out time and
hang out oh yeah you're gonna take us
Harris well come on I got a guest
room my guest room's taken unfortunately
but yeah that's because I always get
that it's like wait we're coming can we
Crush at your
place and barbecue right Harris Barbe oh
yeah if you're here I'm cooking I'm I'm
might be in California but I'm a Texas
boy I'm cooking good food for you oh I'm
coming over for your barbecue Dam well
come on I do them once a month wait
where are you from in Texas
uh so I mean I I get the best of both
worlds because of it I'm from about 25
minutes uh East or I guess west of
Louisiana so it only takes about half an
hour to get over there so we got good
Texas food and we got all the cage in
Louisiana food and it's oh it's got the
best man oh my God I used to to be much
heavier much
heavier yeah California thinned you and
made you healthier right that's what oh
yeah I moved out here my my mentor
playright the the guy that uh convinced
me to move out here was like all right
get fatter and funnier or lose it all
and I was like well I know what I should
do so oh I love it that's awesome okay
well we have to do barbecue man oh yeah
we have before this stream Harris walked
past the camera in that shirt and you
look ripped I'm like what have you been
doing
nothing I've been eating like crap for
seven months I need to actually go back
and start doing well it's too tight or
you've been you've been hitting the
weights I love it good for you dude I
just started exercising again because I
had um because I had a full hip
replacement I am
titanium but you know when you run does
it go I do I to I I mean
I'm I am not a cosplayer as my friends
know but I'm thinking about doing it
because I think it'd be too much fun
just like draw a little prosthetic on it
um but it is it is so much fun so mainly
what I do is I we love to hike and so
doing the walks the height just live in
California it's amazing we can do well
it's the same for the best part you've
got gorgeous walks and Heights man so
yeah that's what I do when I that's why
we brought that Caravan and go up to
North Wales and I keep doing my videos
up there but to hike walk
and just be on the beach and just even
in it's crappy I'm going in about three
weeks because it shuts the because it's
on a park and it shuts that's GNA be
freezing oh yeah oh God I took Harry my
dog last year in November and we nearly
died it was all right when we walking
the w we at the beach the wind was
behind us then we turned around like
sand blasted oh god oh man his
eyelashes you guys get you guys get much
worse hold on Pardon Me no
dog yeah he's a Ming around um I you
know I one of the things I love about
Lac is we usually have great weather so
it's December in Los Angeles is usually
gorgeous so you get to see the mountains
it's crisp it's you know in essence it
be your fall but that's our winter and
you know it should be really good this
year we're I think the vendors I'm
working with them on the um with a
couple of guys that are doing the
Masquerade so it's it should it should
be crazy fun and they've got quite a
good lineup this year and I know they're
hoping that wraps
up but you know I was trying to do a 12
Monkeys reunion but that didn't happen
so I've just started watching 12 Monkeys
I did I I started to watch it when it
first came out but I got I got a bit
bored of it and or I think it might have
been on the network and then I sort of
changed and I I didn't watch it anyway
but if somebody was telling me go no
second
season and I was like okay and I'm just
getting it's also good to look at where
Terry malus came from right how he's
developed as a showrunner and a
screenwriter I mean it's just it's
really fun to watch the the progression
of where he is now looking at hard he's
done so I I just think a lot of that is
cool rumors is dis Disney throwing
everything at him to trying and get him
on a long-term contract at the moment
he's doing escape the wi mountain and
they want they they've got a slew of
things they love him to do but he's
still got half an eye on maybe Paramount
might do
Legacy he doesn't want to no and also I
don't think he wants to commit to one
Studio I think you know he as it was
with Paramount committed you know for
three seasons that he's already done and
I think what he would love to do from
what I've heard I don't know him
personally this is what I've heard from
a friend who knows him really well is
that he really wants to to do what most
show on screen always want to do which
is
to do a bigger Spectrum a broader
spectrum of different things now he
loves I mean I don't think he's going to
go away from that but I think he'd like
to try some different things I mean it's
why he's doing escape from Mountain you
know it's quite that's quite a broad
spectrum but a superhero thing he's
already written as well that he's trying
to get Disney to take
off they
might I would love I would love to see
something that he's done it's a
superhero and that' be amazing yeah yeah
it's just it is supposed to be a bit
Boise a bit like I think it was oh I did
read a bit superhero fantasy type of
thing but oh okay something he read a
while he wrote it a while ago but he's
defin been trying to get it made ever
since and struggling off the back of a
card
though I think he can pretty much do
what he wants to do I think it's finding
the right deal who gives him the best
packet for what he wants to do next I
mean he is lined up for other things
that were on hold because of the stripes
so that's part of the problem is you've
got people and look I don't know if
that's part of the problem with Stargate
is that you've got it may have been they
have people that were lined up that were
ready to go and the strike screwed it up
that you know they if you have a lineup
with a showrunner and then all of a
sudden they've got to go do something
else because that's what's up next on
their
production you you got to you got to
scramble
unfortunately so that wouldn't surprise
me if they have had to sort of if
they've been forced to rethink and maybe
maybe they will go back series or
whatever because the people that like
you said like people that had lined up
for the movie maybe are just not
available anymore exactly it could be
simple as that right I mean and this is
this was an argument that I I still have
with a lot of Ip owners or Distributors
is just be transparent ter notilus I
mean James Gun May overdo it but terus
is the perfect example of being
transparent he he will go on Twitter I
refuse to call it X or he'll go on uh on
an interview and he'll say hey this is
what I was doing this is what happened
here's where I'm going next yeah they
were just
transparent
about being honest with the fans with
the stardate fans let's say Amazon's PR
the the folks who know came out and said
look we put together a timeline of
what's happening and we're and we don't
have any guarantees and we can't commit
to anything that this is what we what we
want fans to
know we're not idiots and I think that's
part of the problem is that I think that
a lot of studios and IP owners still
presume that fans are
um I don't think they presume that we're
stupid but I think that they presume
that we're naive that we are so
enthusiastic that we're such freaks and
look I get it there's lots of TOS that
we're going to take something like that
we're going to run with it and we're
never going to accept anything else and
I know that that fear is what drives
almost everything that corporate PR does
and the biggest arguments and the
biggest headbutting that I've ever had
was with corporate Communications with
PR because I would want to always be
saying guys we should be able to get up
in a con and say hey this is what we
want to do we can't do it because of
these reasons hang in there and they
don't do that I think it's it
underestimates your fans and I think it
is disrespectful
of trusting fans to be able to handle
the give and take of the entertainment
industry Stargate
xfiles Buffy a couple of others were
some of the first that pulled back the
curtain on what was happening behind the
scenes where fans wanted to see it they
wanted to engage with the writers
showrunners with the directors and
having that happen gave a crash course
of Education of how it works how
decisions are made so don't
underestimate fans they're going to
understand why a decision had to be put
on hold if you came forward and said hey
Co strike we can't we couldn't make the
decision we wanted we lost the people
that we had lined up because of that
hang in there we're going to get there
yeah but they don't do that it'll
probably come out at some point but
they're going through a bit of this with
battar at the moment that it keeps going
backwards and forward and it
looks the fatigue fans have
yeah KN knowing what's going on in the
background obviously we we we try and
tell people what we hear but if they
came out and said it and they were like
look this is what's going on we we were
speaking to pengu Parker but then this
this went under something happened blah
blah blah whatever the de the deal is
whatever it is as long as if they told
us right we'd be like okay yeah we're
disappointed obviously but at least we
know yeah and see the reaction as well
they would get a
reaction positive it might just give
them more of this metadata that they
love to try and oh actually we told them
were people crying in the street let's
do this might well you the the third
hand rumors that you and I both heard
about why my name is not going to be put
forward it's because of those arguments
on you know the the the head buding that
I always had and some knockdown drag out
fights of which I completely and let's
be clear people I worked with at MGM
with some very few exceptions were
amazing people I was very lucky at Fox
at MGM to have an amazing team that I
got to work with these are people who
have gone on to do just kickass projects
and gave me freedom to do what I need to
do with fans but the problem the nature
of PR corporate Communications PR is to
protect the
corporation it is not to give
communication to give information to the
audience the fans so their very job is
going to be at odds with me from the
beginning and I understand it but my
problem was is that you have to find a
compromise and there was no compromise
it was no we're not going to address
this we're not going to talk about it
we're not going to acknowledge it even
if I wanted to acknowledge something and
so one of the reasons why that became a
constant issue is that I would go to
cons where it wasn't being written about
at the time because you could go to
gaycon or you go to San Diego and you
could have a panel and for the most part
what you said at a panel was not
recorded in an interview or an article
if you if you it so I would say hey this
is what happened this is why you know
one of the biggest issues with Stargate
command is we never got beyond the six
territories the
initial and so I would be really honest
hey guys this is why we struggle with
this MGM has existing distribution deals
we can't we can't um bypass this but if
we have this fiveyear plan in three
years then I can go directly to these
other territories in Brazil
Etc there's a t-shirt that we made
because my phrase was we're working on
it and it became you know a joke
internally with fans that I would just
say okay we're working on it because
that's what I would tell people it was
the truth but I would also tell them
here's the reasoning about it I want to
fry
[Music]
[Laughter]
up I didn't expect anyone to like
mention it on here
but sorry stream of
Consciousness okay so private message
yes we no we're going to put it hly I
think one of the things I was told was a
lot of PR and stuff is really private is
because um the corporations if they knew
if we knew everything the all the
indecision and stuff that goes on we
would know that they're they they would
look like
morons oh well I mean just think
about they all human hi kri all right
and it's it is natural for all of
corporations streaming companies
Production Studios to have internal
conversations that's part of the
creative process as fans we need to
respect that and not be disingenuous
that we wouldn't be exactly the same if
we were sitting at those tables you're
spending 50 million quid on something
you want to make sure you're going the
right way and so you got to be you gota
you you have to as a fan if we're going
to have you can't can't have it one way
as a fan if you want to see behind the
curtain you have to accept what comes
with that which is these are human
beings who are doing the best they can
most of the time who have
absolute goals to create something that
people love and make money for most
people it's in that order I want to
create something I want people to love
it and we want to make money running the
problems is when you have the Gated
Community f or that the money is first
then it's ass backwards unfortunately
then you're making decisions based on
that outcome as opposed to what's good
or what audience is there I mean that is
again that's why I went into what I've
gone into is that fandom is there pay
attention to it nurture it don't ignore
us don't pretend that it isn't there and
worse don't nurture the relationship and
then drop it off a cliff that happens a
lot
where the damn customer for the love of
God
yeah yeah where where the reason why you
do it in the first place so think right
before we we sign off then and say thank
you so much again for Jenny for for
coming along for hope we the first time
of many times we get to see Jen
particularly if this ever gets announced
but let's go around the to quickly
before we go and just I just want to
know what do you think is going to be
announced movie TV series whatever but
what do you want to get announced just
from your good Matt what we we'll end on
Jenny movie it's going to be the movie
that's what I think it's going to be I'd
love a TV series but it's if it's going
to follow I mean I'm happy either
way uh yeah this year announced I think
so I think so I made a Tik Tok yesterday
about the Stargate timekeepers game now
having a date of December 12th so if
it's before
then yeah happy days but honestly
nothing surprises me these days
Slytherin will want that Slytherin will
really really want them to announce the
movie before the game comes out yeah but
Harris what do you think think and
want well I want it to happen today I
want to log off this and be like all
right well look at this you know get a
little press releasing that but thinking
about it with timekeepers in the 12th
and we just put it out there if they
want to do a little something at La
ComiCon that wouldn't be a bad thing
it'd be one of the bigger things that
they could do something at that's kind
of left in in this kind of General time
span right now
yeah and it's fun it correlates with the
game I'm not sure the exact dates but
it's usually that second or third
weekend of December so it might actually
come out right around the same time so
it would be that very it'd be two weeks
before time
Keepers Kind of Perfect Kind of Perfect
that that would be very nice to be able
to do that and then go into the new year
with a little momentum running because
that's what we're here to do we're here
to keep the momentum going so be a
little transparent give us those little
acknowledgements so we can help that
momentum keep going right maybe we just
figured it out maybe only listen to
us then go on then what do you what do
you think will happen what do you want
to
happen as a
fan I thought it was going to be a movie
now I don't know I got to be honest I
think it's it's really up in the it it
was pretty it was pretty hardcore
everybody was convinced it was going to
be a movie now I'm not so
sure I have no idea when it's going to
be announced no clue
literally not no feeling most times I
can get a gut feeling I can't get a gut
feeling on this it literally could be
tomorrow today La ComiCon March I just
don't know I think it all depends on the
stars aligning for Amazon and and
honestly I think that that's what it
comes down to that they need certain
things to
align internally and from a production
standpoint I get that what I would love
to happen is I would love a citadel
model that would be it would be effing
amazing I think I don't care if it
starts with a movie and goes to series
but if we could get a citadel model that
as a fan and as a producer i' be over
the moon I think it'd be brilliant it
would take advantage of your
International fans automatically you
don't get into international territory
distribution issues it'd be great and
you'd come up with great
stories it's the sort of show that
particularly if we think it's progressed
the way it should have done if you think
logically how star should have
progressed if it was real it's it makes
100% we were already going that the the
the Atlantis was an international
Expedition right so it makes sense and
it would have been exposed to the public
potentially which I know was always a a
theme that we all as fans debate so you
never know you could do great you such
cool stuff with that have y sorry I just
just thinking about it like that have
y'all seen Star Wars Visions yeah just
because that I think that'd be a decent
model not necessarily the first season
where they outsourc it all to Japanese
Studios and different Studios but the
second season where the first season
might have been a little stronger the
second season was awesome where it was
different Studios from different
countries for each different episode
yeah what what if they did that and
correlated the whole season and made
seven or eight 10 12 however many
episode TV movies the supplemental
content that you could do with that like
we were trying to do with Origins would
be so
cool yeah I just just we just I think
you're right Jen that I think a movie
was absolutely sewn on
until
um until that all the the studios just
went shut down and I think I think we
were further along than we know possibly
yeah with with the development
I think it's all up in the air now and I
think the meeting that we both talked
about a couple of weeks ago where they
basically said all right guys you can
keep going on about series why I think
that's a lot and I also think um I heard
that
um managers basically asked the pr
marketing people all these projects that
are coming up we want to review the
plans before we start announcing things
and apparently Stargate was not included
in that review oh interesting okay and
that I think might be telling either
it's because they're about to announce
it and so they don't need to look at it
we already know what we're doing crack
on
or they might be deciding to change and
if they change I think we I don't I
think it could be three years until he
gets dget yeah if they change I think I
don't think there's any question that
you're right that development had
definitely gotten to a particular good
point because they supposedly were
announcing at sdcc at San Diego but
uh whatever's going to happen now could
drop any time I think the biggest issue
to your point is that whatever those
stars that were aligned are no longer
aligned soank whether it was crank in
the parka fell out or that J Sala
changed how she wants to approach it I
do think it's encouraging that they had
this meeting two weeks ago I don't put a
lot of stock in it because it could have
just been informational as opposed to
production development but it was
encouraging regard I just you know
honestly I just don't think that
everything's in alignment yet and I
think that Amazon's going to be very
careful hopefully they'll be very
careful announcing anything with a new
franchise I mean if you look at their
campaigns for their own franchises they
are very very carefully crafted very
specific they have very uh delineated
rules about how these campaigns get
announced released they've got uh teaser
trailers content fans lined up
ambassadors lined up that's not done
yeah I I do wonder if we're starting to
see the like say with emailing us maybe
emailing gate World emailing that they
seem to be trying to just begin those
little tentative yeah conversations and
get maybe getting a feel for who they
want to work with maybe um and then it's
hopefully but that could be very early
very tentative
very but it could could be that shift
which we've been hoping for and if it is
then look we'll wait I'd rather they do
it right than rush it to try to get
something out there because if they do
that look this fan base will come back
it could be completely screwed up be
horrible if something comes after that
we're still going to check it out what
because I I I forget there was a time
where people were saying well you know
if you do something and it isn't what
everybody likes they're never going to
come back to survey come on seriously
that that's not true for any fan base
but what you do have is you have
unfortunately a um the law of averages
you're going to have a direct
proportional Dro in how many fans are
willing to come back so there's an
attrition that happens and I think that
that's what you don't want to have here
you want to be transparent you want to
try to get news out I think them
reaching out to you guys and the Darren
is you know
huge I don't know what they're going to
do with it and I hope I hope
that this is is indicative of a change
in Direction with the meeting they had
two weeks ago this I I genuinely hope
that that
is encouraging in the right direction
yeah let's hope so let's hope so Jenny
thank you again so so much sorry I talk
so much I
apologize more about you guys I'm so
sorry it's why we invited you we'll let
we'll let matx speak next time probably
um but no no thank you again so much for
giving us your time and um and you're
just your knowledge which is why because
you just you're it's great just sitting
there listening to you to be honest I me
I feel like I'm a viewer like but it's
whatever well I appreciate that I just
it's obvious that I love it so anytime
that people want to talk about the
industry not just Stargate but about the
entertainment industry and what's
happening and I I just I know that
people that are watching I know they're
going to laugh because this is my thing
I really want people to feel encouraged
about what's happening creatively in
this industry don't get discouraged
about what's happening with Amazon or
with Netflix or with the studios with
Warner Brothers pay attention to
Independent creators go search out
artists books graphic novels web series
web Tunes animation the work that's
being done around the world right now
that is independent creators and artists
is
amazing ultimately while Stargate
important to us in general sci-fi
fantasy is having a Renaissance that's
amazing so it's
great love it I know these things come
in ABS and waves but it justes feel like
yeah we're in a decent sci-fi and not
and like I said not maybe the big budget
sci-fi but
the Sci-Fi is just the perfect genre for
anybody with an imagination to go I want
to talk about this and I want to do it
in a different way and it'll just be
right it's there's so many good things
out there it's it
is the amount of books that are selling
in sci-fi fantasy sci-fi fantasy is now
the number one genre in
Books Okay
so I love it it says it's exciting thank
you for having me thank you so much for
coming and guys and I see you have a
standing invitation
for anytime you want to jump in um Matt
Harris thank you so much for jumping on
again mate you can go and have your
Saturday Matt go and have your fry up
and for everybody in the comments yes I
do now need a Wii so that might be a
little
bit so everyone else just run off and
had one I've had to stay but Jen thank
you so so much thank
you I didn't have a sec wait a sec wait
a sec wait a sec okay bye bye
[Music]